the robust robotics group under the
leadership of professors Nick Roy and
Seth teller at the MIT computer science
and artificial intelligence laboratory
is developing a voice command able
autonomous wheelchair this video shows a
research prototype under development
since 2005 the long-term goals of the
project are to develop intelligent
assistant technology that can work with
a variety of people and the wheelchair
is one example of this kind of
technology our target population
consists of people who have limited
physical mobility and limited physical
control by adding a voice command able
interface and intelligent autonomy to a
person's wheelchair the chair can then
be used by people who may not have the
necessary level of physical ability to
control the wheelchair using a standard
interface such as a joystick we're
developing a range of capabilities from
simply augmenting existing wheelchairs
to developing a fully autonomous powered
wheelchair we are collaborating with the
Boston home a specialized care residence
for adults with progressive neurological
diseases in working with tbh we plan to
develop wheelchairs that can be used by
more tbh residents without assistance
from a caregiver increasing the
independence and quality of life of the
residents
commodity powered wheelchair but we have
added a number of components such as a
low-power laser range scanner to detect
obstacles and provide fine-grained
position tracking for autonomous control
we have added a microphone to listen to
the wheelchair user and speakers to
respond using speech on this wheelchair
we have added a computer for sensor
processing and intelligent
decision-making when the wheelchair does
not need to provide fully autonomous
navigation and control we can deploy a
small PDA tablet instead of a full
sensor suite and computer the smaller
tablet can easily be added to existing
wheelchairs that still allows us to
provide voice interactions so that the
wheelchair can give information to its
user for example about daily activities
the tablet also provides Wi-Fi
connectivity that allows it to estimate
the wheelchair position at a room level
and Synn the estimated position to
caregivers so the nurses can more easily
stay aware of the wheelchair users
health and needs the onboard computer or
tablet can process speech and respond
via speech to user queries in the future
we plan to use the tablet as an
alternate way to interact with
wheelchair users for populations who
have difficulty with speech for full
autonomous navigation and control the
wheelchair can use a laser range scanner
to detect obstacles and estimation in
the map this hook will you laser range
scanner sends out a plane of infrared
light which it uses to measure the
distance to obstacles around it by
comparing the positions of obstacles
around the wheelchair to the positions
of obstacles in a map the wheelchair can
estimate its position in a map as it
moves around the wheelchair can use the
same laser sensor to explore new
environments and build new Maps even if
an object is not in the map the sensor
allows the wheelchair to detect the new
obstacle and replan around it the
technologies for autonomous navigation
and control are not new although they
have not been widely deployed on
autonomous wheelchairs our project has a
number of innovative aspects that are
designed to make autonomous navigation
and control more easily deployed and
adopted by the general public
for example we are building on
well-known robot mapping algorithms that
can learn the floorplan of environments
and developing algorithms that allow a
wheelchair to learn new environments and
build maps from a narrated guided tour
the wheelchair can take instructions
from a human caregiver to learn the
names of places in the map this natural
language understanding
we'll make it much easier for caregivers
to deploy the wheelchair in new
environments and make it easier for
users to use the wheelchair
you
once the chair understands the users
desired destination it navigates a route
through the previously learned map to
that intended destination
go down the hallway pass the door and
along the railing until you get to the
refrigerator in the kitchen on your
right we are also developing algorithms
that will allow the robot to be guided
through unfamiliar environments for
example the robot can follow simple
spoken directions to an unlabeled
location in the map by reasoning about
how people use everyday objects as
landmarks for navigation for a user with
difficulty communicating the chair can
learn the users behavior and mobility
patterns over time in order to improve
ease of use for example when the user
has a daily routine the chair can
anticipate the users desired
destinations and plan routes they are
proactively reducing the user burden of
fully specifying each destination as we
add more wheelchairs with knowledge of
where they are we can give residents of
the Boston home the ability to find each
other
the intelligent wheelchair project
you